[Musik]
die neue armin laschet biografie bringt
eine historische sensation zu tage der
ministerpräsident von nrw soll direkter
nachkomme von kaiser karl dem großen
sein
für zdf royal reise ich nach aachen um
bei einem historiker weitere
erkenntnisse zu erlangen
für montag hat professor müller guten
morgen ich freue mich dass sie da sind
wollen wir in meinem büro gehen ja gott
wollen sie sich noch umziehen vorher
oder bleibt das so bleibt so welche
eigenschaften von karl dem großen finden
sie in armin laschet wieder ja was man
nicht wiederfindet ist die körpergröße
karl der große ist natürlich ein
stattlicher mann gewesen armin laschet
ist er sozusagen der westlichen napoleon
artigen größe verhaftet der historiker
nimmt solche abstammung dinge eigentlich
gar nicht ernst oder nicht sehr ernst
aber armin laschet schon ja vielleicht
ja auch sein bruder es ist ja echt stolz
darauf von karl dem großen
möglicherweise abzustammen
wissenschaftlich ist es würde ich sagen
im positiven sinne des wortes fragwürdig
und mit ein bisschen phantasie kann ich
mir da auch armin laschet doch drunter
vorstellen würde ich sagen sehr sehr
sehr sehr sehr viel fantasie also ich
komme offenbar mit ihrem grad an
fantasie da nicht mit am ehesten
vielleicht noch kriegt man es mit den
haaren hin
und weiter geht's in die hauptstadt hier
im altehrwürdigen meister sei zu berlin
wird die neue armin laschet biografie
vorgestellt und zwar von niemand
geringerem als markus söder ist er sich
nicht der gefahren bewusst die da auf
ihn lauern
karl der große hat er die
selbstständigkeit bayerns beendet sehen
sie die gefahr dann auch bei kaiser
armin laschet
also ich glaube dass der armin laschet
ein unglaublich bürgerlicher mensch ist
und dass er eigentlich da überhaupt
keine verbindungen hat zuteil dem großen
ganz im gegenteil der möchte er
deutschland voranbringen europa und
nicht wie karl der große regierenden der
regierte er vom sattel aus sind zwar
auch sehr hart also hat es armin laschet
nicht jetzt doch und weicher typ er ist
nicht hart genug eine sensibler mensch
sensibler mensch
hier im staatstheater mainz wird armin
laschet gleich auftreten armin laschet
oder wie er mit vollem adelstitel heißt
armin laschet die herolde verkünden sein
kommen lasse die schalmeien erklingen
[Musik]
geschmeidigkeit die aufrechte
sitzhaltung die kraftvolle stimme das
ist 1000 jahre genetisches best of
germany dass wir hier erleben und über
ihm da sehen wir eine krone das ist
natürlich kein zufall dass es eine
vorausschau auf seine baldige
inthronisierung ja armin laschet heute
im anthrazitfarbenen regierungs zwirn
der wird traditionell geschneidert vom
kultur jedes landtags kabel von karstadt
die brille dazu selbstverständlich aus
fensterglas um ihn menschlicher zu
machen um seine unfehlbarkeit zu
kaschieren
armin der große trägt heute königsblaue
socken mit den traditionellen zwei
löchern die im familienwappen des hauses
laschet für das fehlen von furcht und
kompetenz stehen
verlass dich hat nur ein geschenk für
sie eine eine merchandising tasse mit
armin der große sind ja direkt danach
komme von dem großen chips wären sie
nicht gefällt einfach fallenlassen
scherben bringen glück und das kann man
gebrauchen
und jetzt fahre ich mit der von ihren
gebühren gekauften kutsche zurück nach
köln
[Musik]
was denn über meinen arsch geigensolo
war doch versprochen ihr könnt ja in der
zeit den kanal abonnieren
[Musik]